welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division is creeping into
the shadows of
witchcraft toying with us over whether
or not evan peters represents an
actual link to the marvel multiverse as
this house of m inspired series seems to
be setting up well no
answers on evan but episode 7 plugged
nexus antidepressant medication most
likely a reference to wanda being a
nexus bean for the marvel comics
a character detached from any one
reality with influence over the broader
multiverse of realities so one division
still looks like it's setting up the
multiverse just not in the way we
expected like rather than evan peters
being the key to the multiverse
wanda is by re-examining the clues given
to us these past few episodes we
actually have an idea of what this
multiverse
birth will look like and like any birth
it's gonna be gross
might wanna wait outside and before we
begin this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
so episode 7 reveals agnes agatha
harkness a witch similarly powered as
the scarlet witch she conjures up her
own purple wiggly woos to match
wanda's red ones it is implied that
agatha uses her magic to control evan
peters character
but this agave all along sequence also
shows her winky net smiling at talking
directly to
us breaking the fourth wall as this
episode's title foretells
however i do not think this makes agatha
a nexus being herself
because then what would agatha want or
need from wanda agatha would already be
god level
and unlike wanda in full cognitive
control of those god level abilities
in the comics wanda maximoff possesses
chaos magic which she got from the demon
chathan
the original author of the darkhold
agatha here possesses what looks like
the mcu's version of the darkhold
so we can assume she has similar powers
as wanda but
with one key difference in the mcu
wanda's powers were activated by
an infinity stone the mind stone and in
episode 8 it's looking like we're going
to flash back to wanda's sokovian
history
the moment that cosmic radiation
activated her now we already know that
that radiation is crucial to the
properties of the west view hex
darcy identified it as cmbr and she and
hayward said it was relic radiation
dating back to the big bang
the same event that wong explained in
infinity war produced the infinity
stones
this same radiation empowers monica
rambo after it passes through her three
times
transforming her into it looks like
photon and allowing her to see this
radiation coursing through everything
like neo seeing the matrix code so that
infinity stone connection
is what makes wanda a unique witch a
nexus being and i think this is what
agatha lacks what she wants from wanda
because despite agatha pulling the
strings behind westview if you read
closely into those lyrics of agatha all
along it doesn't say anything about her
creating the hecks
[Music]
messing up everything as in crashing
someone else's party not hosting the
party herself
because why would you mess up your own
party to use one division's extended
metaphor of a television series agnes
may be the director of it but she is not
the series creator
see in tv the creator showrunner not the
director has the real power
so what does this tell us about how this
isolated west view crisis will
explode into a multiverse one that could
give us the x-men we so desperately want
and again thanks to squarespace for
sponsoring this video squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and to run your business
are you looking for a website to sell
your wares say you want the world to see
your elaborate one division fan art of
who you think the big bad will be and
you want the world to see them before
the next episode comes out and debunks
that theory entirely
well you can present your fanfic and any
of your other work to the world
using squarespace's professional
portfolio designs
display projects and customizable
galleries and add password protected
pages
to share private work with clients you
can auto post your content to twitter to
facebook or tumblr they have built-in
mobile websites and a really sick
mailing list feature to stay in touch
with your customers squarespace will
even sell you a url
somebody uh go check to see if
zombievisionismojo.com is available
yeah i don't know if we want it but it's
good to know head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain that's
squarespace.comrockstars for 10 off your
first purchase of website or a domain
well agave seems to be a witch capable
of small scale sorcery that she
gets from her spell book the darkhold
something i believe to be a vessel of
the demon mephisto
maybe lots of other demons too agatha
uses wanda's unique infinity
stone-powered sorcery to create this
city-wide hex
probably under the promise of being able
to bring vision back of working through
her trauma whatever it is
but it ends up trapping both of them
inside really her goal is to steal
wanda's nexus abilities the ability to
branch into the multiverse and as we've
seen through this series this hex is
for the children it's pressuring wanted
to manifest her kids
billy and tommy and now agatha has taken
them one possibility is she could plan
to trick wanda into
transferring her nexus powers over to
agatha in exchange for these boys back
but what agatha won't tell wanda is that
these boys are actually from the
darkhold
pieces of mephisto's soul unleash hell
demons fun
but then what agatha hasn't counted on
is that wanda's infinity stone-powered
magic
is even more potent than anyone thought
fully resurrecting vision
irradiating monica rambo in a photon
giving wanda some allies in this fight
that's why agatha has been trying her
best to keep wanda separate from these
two
but in the end they're probably gonna be
one deceiving graces meanwhile
outside westview it is clear hayward
intends on launching an
attack on this hex make sure the team
has everything they need
we launched today and as a trigger happy
weapons nut
i think it's fair to assume hayward
might be trying to nuke west
view if he does that wanda beginning to
understand her nexus abilities
could save westview by redirecting the
blast
and the sudden exertion of radiation
back into the radiation based hex itself
exploding it into a spectrum of hex
prisms a multiverse of alternate warped
realities
now in the breakdown i discussed how a
hexagonal prism with these sharp
angles is kind of like a tesseract in
that it is a hypothetical fourth
dimensional form
whose angles don't really make sense
they only make sense as a
three-dimensional prism
as that fourth dimensional object passes
through our 3d plane
in other words this hexagonal prism is
not long for this reality its
design itself means it must exist in
another dimension
once this all explodes wanda could
escape with her children into one of
these alternate hex realities
this way one division would not be the
full events of house of m just yet it's
really just the opening
act to split to reality into an array
creating a chaotic time stream that will
be used as a backdrop for
loki and a spider-verse conflict coming
in spider-man 3. we actually have proof
that the world of spider-man
has been affected by whatever happens in
one division because
in spider-man far from home which
remember is set seven months after wanda
vision peter parker gets super excited
by the idea of a multiverse i'm sorry
you're saying there's a multiverse
madness that his teacher mr dell keeps
identifying as
witchcraft you know being a man of
science
witches and then doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness will likely be the
climactic
showdown of this multiverse saga the
house of m
final act in which i expect the
multiverse will collapse back into one
reality
sucking in other nexus beings like jean
grey and the other mutants
franklin richards in the fantastic four
and kang the conqueror
setting him up in ant-man in the wasp
quantum mania you see we don't need evan
peters to be
fox quick silver to birth the mcu
multiverse in wanavision we just need
wanda to be a nexus being under attack
by a witch and a dumbass to drop a nuke
on him
if you want to support this channel the
best way is to check out one of our many
great merch options at
norockstarsmirch.com like this great and
unusual couple shirt
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for all your wanna vision
questions thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you